hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president-elect joe biden is forging
ahead setting up his administration
and declaring that his transition to the
white house is well underway
while president trump and his team
continue to contest the election results
filing lawsuits in several states fox
news sunday host chris wallace discusses
the legal challenges from the trump
campaign
the upcoming senate runoff races in
georgia and rumors president trump
is starting a digital media company
states in cities across the nation are
tightening restrictions as the number of
coronavirus cases in the u.s
continue to rise the surge in infections
and precautions
re-sparking questions and doubts about
an economic rebound
businessman and fox news contributor
john layfield weighs in
on how business owners and investors may
be impacted
this winter plus commentary from guy
benson host of the guy benson show
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm dana perino i'm brian kilmeade i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
[Music]
friday november 13 2020 i'm chris foster
even if president trump loses his fight
to stay in office a lot of
president-elect biden's agenda could
live or die depending on who controls
the senate
that comes down to two runoff elections
in georgia if
democrats were able to flip and oust the
two republicans
in those two seats it would be a 50-50
senate and assuming that joe biden
is the president and kamala harris is
the vice president
she breaks the tie and suddenly chuck
schumer is the senate majority leader
we talked to fox news sunday host chris
wallace i'm lisa brady
a vaccine may be the light at the end of
the pandemic tunnel
but there's still a long way to go and
many more small businesses
may fall by the wayside we're going to
have a wave of bankruptcies if we don't
figure out a way to keep them alive
until this vaccine takes effect and i'm
guy benson i've got the final word
on the fox news rundown
[Music]
president-elect biden is proceeding with
business as usual meeting with
transition advisors naming a chief of
staff a coronavirus task force and
filling other jobs
house speaker nancy pelosi says about
president trump's refusal to concede and
the other republicans supporting his
lawsuits over ballot counting
they're engaged in an absurd circus
right now refusing to accept reality
the republicans are shamefully
pretending of proceeding
without recognizing what our
responsibility
is president trump is keeping up the
fight with lawsuits in several states
called for joe biden
white house spokeswoman kelly mcinerney
tells fox
we deserve to have an accurate count and
we deserve to ask questions when there
are really
serious affidavits out there making
serious allegations
the campaign makes several arguments
like dead people and non-residents
voting
or that its observers couldn't get close
enough at minimum it would take
overturning about 75 000 votes in
pennsylvania and wisconsin and winning
georgia and north carolina to change the
election results
i don't know that they have a clear plan
uh
but the president at least seems to
think that
this election was stolen from him so
they're going to pursue
uh any possibilities of vote fraud
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday there is also
the possibility and i have to say i find
this kind of distressing
if you can tie up the state long enough
but the
the electors have to vote on december
14th
there is a provision that the state
legislature
steps in and they name the electors so
you know it it is possible if even in a
state like
pennsylvania that is uh you know went
for trump for biden rather by tens of
thousands of votes
you could have the republican control
controlled state legislature
come in and name trump electors not
biden electors so that's a possibility
and i think
most you know and i say i think all
these things are swirling around they
don't have to sit there and do it for
one reason
i think most especially the the
trump camp believes that his
voters uh his supporters want him
to be seen as fighting for himself
and fighting for them and so they they
they don't want him to concede they
don't want him to say i lost
and i think they at least this is the
trump camps
perception and i think the president's
perception that he's now already
reportedly talking about running in 2024
that it is a better thing to be the
aggrieved
robbed president in in you know in exile
than to just be a losing presidential
candidate yeah sure um
if he runs in 2024 or even just in his
business ventures he wants to be able to
sell himself
um as a winner now most not all but most
republicans in congress if
they've said anything at all or
supporting the president in this most i
assume believe
that the election's over and have their
own reasons for keeping it up
well i think there are a couple of
things going on there one you don't want
to be on the wrong side of donald trump
i mean he still has
enormous 80 90 support among republicans
and
one tweet uh from the president saying
you know congressman so-and-so has been
disloyal
uh could be political oblivion for him
uh
that's number one number two remember
this election forget about the
presidential race
the battle for control of the senate is
not over and
you know you've got these two special
elections on january 5th
in georgia the purdue seat the leftler
seat
and i think republicans want to do
everything they can
to mobilize people to come out and vote
and again i think they believe
that you know a grieve grievance-filled
party uh you know this election has been
stolen on the national level
may be a more effective campaigning tool
than just saying
we lost yeah a lot of money a lot of
attention on those two january runoffs
the democrats of course need to win both
uh you think they have a shot
yeah you know it like sounds like the
line from dumb and dumber you're saying
there's a chance
uh yeah they have a shot i mean i think
at this point
you would say that the republicans are
the favorite it's still georgia even if
joe biden ends up winning it
but there was a poll that was that came
out
after the election the runoffs in one
case you've got david perdue the
incumbent republican senator against
john osof
and the other you have the reverend
rafael
warnock against the incumbent republican
senator kelly lefler
and they were both within the margin of
error i think one was 49 48 the other
was
50 46 so sure they got a shot
and can you imagine the amount of money
that is going to be spent because this
won't just be two random races
these are literally races for control of
the senate if
if democrats were able to flip and oust
the two republicans
in those two seats it would be a 50-50
senate and assuming that joe biden is
the president
and uh kamala harris is the vice
president
she breaks the tie and suddenly chuck
schumer is the senate majority leader so
there will be literally hundreds of
millions of dollars spent on those two
races
in less than two months uh we're seeing
record record
chronovirus cases there's no reason to
believe the next couple of months won't
get even worse with the colder weather
and the holidays coming up
uh joe biden one of his coronavirus
advisors dr michael
osterholm his name is says we could end
this with a four to six week shutdown
but you'd have to have the government
paying to float businesses and workers
now the money part just isn't going to
happen even though
even if you could get people to buy into
it yeah and the answer is you couldn't
get people to buy into it
i mean to go back to last march and have
a complete shutdown
and we never really did have a complete
shutdown we had a complete shutdown
in a few states uh new york new jersey
connecticut
but we didn't have a big a complete
national shutdown and and
and to do that all across the country
because this has now become
a a national phenomenon uh
isn't going to happen but i will say
this i find it
distressing not necessarily surprising
but distressing
that all the focus in this white house
with the president with the vice
president seems to be
on finding ways to fight the results of
this election
and that's fine if they want to do that
but we are in a
critical point right now with 130
140 000 cases a day 60 000 piece
people hospitalized and we've not heard
one word from the president
on the corona virus and you know he's
still
as as they all like to say in these
final days you're the president until
noon on january 20th why aren't the
president and the vice president
speaking to the nation and doing
anything they can
to try to push solutions and you know we
kind of it's not magic short of
lockdowns
where masks socially distance you know
what to do with thanksgiving
you know they have a bully pulpit but
they don't they seem to be focused on
the election and not
on the health of their fellow americans
yeah and still after all these many many
months it's still
to some people a big political thing
wearing a mask and
uh i don't know if you're hearing as
much talk about the whole thing as a
fraud and it's no worse
than the flu than we did in the spring
but you're still seeing
uh these maskless rallies popping up no
that's right and
you know when on election night when the
president uh
had his quote uh victory celebration
in the white house at i think it was 2
30 in the morning
there were a couple of hundred people
there and i've seen pictures of it
without masks
and so forth for five people in that
group
in the east room of the white house got
the coronavirus
uh including uh his his top political
adviser a felony brian jack his
white house chief of staff uh mark
meadows
so again you know you can do a couple of
things at one time and if they want to
press their political
arguments about the campaign fine but
they are also
the president and the vice president the
people in charge of handling the corona
virus in this country
and on capitol hill on the financial
side
clearly nothing's going to happen with
relief there
until maybe until
joe biden is sworn in no well yeah i
mean there's a possibility of but again
you know you say to yourself you're the
president and the vice president
until january 20th why aren't they
getting nancy pelosi and saying okay the
election's over
let's make a deal let's find something
we can agree on i understand nancy
pelosi has not been the most cooperative
person in this
she you know it bears her share of the
blame but
keep working to try to get a bailout for
people
uh who are losing unemployment benefits
and for companies that have long since
lost their payroll protection plan yeah
my understanding is that speaker pelosi
has
maybe made the the perfect the enemy of
the good here where she's held out for
everything she wants instead of taking
something well that's certainly an
argument you can make i mean there's no
no question
you can make that argument of the flip
side of the argument i'm not taking it
aside here
is she thinks they're only going to do
it once and
she doesn't want it to be uh look
the election was a huge problem here and
and and
shame on all of them because they should
have been worried about the country not
whether or not the democrats were going
to get a win or
it was going to play to the president's
political advantage but the election
is over certainly the count the casting
of votes of not the counting of votes
so let's go back and try and work it out
i i
you know i don't understand the inaction
on this part um you know you're as i say
you're president until january 20th at
noon
uh there's this axios report that if
president trump loses he wants to start
a new digital
media company not a tv network but you
know something streaming any advice
any advice what for for the president
yeah to start up a a possible competitor
uh well i i don't you know
i think he should start a bidding war
for with fox for my services i don't
know i mean
it's uh although i don't think i would
be high on his uh on his list
uh although i've always treated him very
fairly i know that
he and some other people think uh that
uh
you know that i somehow sided with biden
in the first debate but
all i would say is if you want to find
out what
hurt you in the first debate mr
president look in the mirror uh
you know that that you know that first
debate and his behavior in that first
debate
i'm not saying it was the most important
event it wasn't obviously the handling
of the coronavirus was
may have cost him the election because
right after that debate and his
his comportment there uh he took a four
or five point hit
in the polls in in the at the very end
of september early october
and you know had he not taken that hit
and had to claw his way back as
he did pretty effectively in the final
days of the campaign he might have won
yeah i'm sure there are a lot of not
terribly politically engaged viewers who
tuned into that debate out of curiosity
and saw
what came off as a bully that they
didn't want to see i mean
obviously it obviously played to his
supporters but maybe not people that he
needed
i don't and i'm not sure it played to
all of his supporters i mean
look he he got 70 million votes it's the
it's the most votes any person has ever
gotten for president
except joe biden in the same election uh
so
you know he obviously had a lot of
support but as you say
in in an election is tight you couldn't
waste any opportunities and this was the
biggest
viewing opportunity of the whole
election more than 70 million people
all right we'll see where we are next
week fox news sunday host chris wallace
thanks for coming on
you bet thank you chris
[Applause]
this is guy benson with your fox news
commentary coming up
with coronavirus cases setting new
records in the u.s
renewed restrictions are sweeping the
country from limits on bars restaurants
and gyms
to mask orders the nation's third
largest city chicago
has a new stay-at-home advisory
beginning monday
stay home unless you have to go out for
essential reasons
do not have guests over avoid
unnecessary travel
and cancel your traditional thanksgiving
plans
mayor lori lightfoot says in her city
alone a thousand more people could die
from covid before year's end if
behaviors don't change
one coronavirus advisor to
president-elect joe biden
is floating the idea of a four to six
week nationwide lockdown
dr michael astra home telling yahoo
finance on wednesday
we could drive the numbers down like
they've done in asia like they did in
new zealand and australia
and then we could really watch ourselves
cruising into the vaccine availability
this as top infectious disease dr
anthony fauci says
we can still avoid another lockdown by
doing a better job with masks and social
distancing
emily williams knight is president and
ceo of the texas restaurant association
we are certainly bracing for more impact
and i can tell you that having lived
through the spring
in texas with restaurant dining rooms
being closed most of our restaurants
won't make it through winter with with
closed dining rooms
she says texas used to have the second
highest number of restaurants in the
country
50 000. they've lost 15 percent already
through september i think we're in a
bind a real bind i think president-elect
biden is correct covet is by far the
biggest thing
in the kind of economic landscape that
is a roadblock for this economy
businessman and former wwe star john
layfield is founder and host to follow
the action
and a fox news contributor we've got to
figure out some way to be able to stay
open and stay open safely and i think we
can
to me there's no reason that you can
have walmart and home depot and cbs stay
open and
their workers not be getting covered not
at a large degree
not enough that you would have to shut
down the store i think you
we should be able to keep open business
in this country and the reason is
i talked to a lot of small businesses
right here in montgomery county where i
live bethesda maryland
and this stimulus check these ppps
they've got them
through to a certain point but if they
go back to 25
which they're voting on this week these
businesses a lot of them say they're
just going to go bankrupt and i just
don't think we can allow that to happen
what about another stimulus bill i mean
obviously they have been able to come to
an agreement in washington
but let's assume for a second they
somehow got something passed
where do you think the money would need
to go first
small businesses first i think feminists
and people's
unemployment benefits that's what's kind
of kept this economy afloat
we we wanted to get a bridge to normalcy
and we didn't know what normalcy was
until we had this announcement from
pfizer and now from moderna
that a vaccine is going to be ready by
the end of the year with distribution
starting at the end of the year toward
the first part of 2021
so we can see the the light at the end
of this pandemic tunnel now and that's
different from before
when people are just asking are we just
going to keep stimulating this economy
and
keep giving up money now we can see
where we are
and these uh small businesses uh we're
going to have a wave
of bankruptcies if we don't figure out a
way to keep them alive
until this vaccine takes effect
so you it sounds like you would say that
another stimulus of some kind is needed
we can't really get from here to there
with the vaccine without with you know
without
trying to save more businesses i
yes that is exactly what i'm saying i'm
not for this government spending i've
been railing on government spending for
some time you know debt
doubled under president bush it doubled
again under president obama and
we were at trillion dollar deficits uh
before the pandemic
and nobody just cared to talk about it
so i'm not in favor of a lot of
government spending
but i think in this case because of this
pandemic this is
something that is unprecedented in our
lifetime at least
and i think you need to find a way to
keep these businesses alive until they
have a chance
for some normalcy because what we've
done is we've given them
enough oxygen to get till now and if
this stimulus runs out you're going to
see a wave of businesses
go under you're going to see people uh
go under as far as personal defaults we
still have 11 million
unemployed right now that's down from a
trough of 22 million
but we have to figure out a way this is
not their fault and we see that we can
have a normal economy
at some respect in the fin sometime in
the spring because of these vaccines
i think we need to help these people and
these businesses get there because
it'll have a multiplier effect on our
economy which stimulate what is stimulus
supposed to have to have to happen i
know at least one
of the president-elect's advisors has
floated the notion that
look we might have to have you know at
least a partial lockdown to get a handle
on what's happening right now with the
virus over a hundred thousand cases a
day
how detrimental would that be for the
economy do you think could we could we
weather a partial lockdown
beyond the renewed restrictions that
have already taken shape around the
country
it depends on how far that partial is oh
yes we could weather it but we're going
to lose a lot of businesses there's an
estimation that the gyms
which is typical of a small business
about 36 to 38 000 gyms in the country a
third of those
are going to go bankrupt and you're
going to see that for restaurants you're
going to see that for small businesses
to me it just isn't fair and it doesn't
make sense
that we can keep open pharmacies we can
keep open big box
retail stores and we can't open up small
businesses i think we can do it and we
can do it safely we have to figure out a
way
to to make safety protocols so that
people can keep these businesses open
and yes i think a lockdown a lockdown of
any kind will be
very detrimental to this economy and i
don't think it's necessary
i'm for mask i am for social distancing
but i've seen it work in so many
different places you look at the sports
leagues
when baseball first started up people
said well this will never work we'll
never get to the world series
you had 50 different sports leagues
professional leagues playing around the
world
at that time if people can figure out
how to do this certainly we in america
can figure out how to do this too
i think it's an unnecessary step to go
backwards in the lockdown
i think safety protocols i think there's
a national mass mandate
i think that's something that could be
very appropriate but as far as
the shutdowns i think it will hurt our
economy it will take us years to get
over
i know that uh mr biden has talked about
a dark winter
uh he had you know and and health
experts too had said that
this could be a rough time of year
combined with flu season
and the surge right now does seem does
seem pretty bad i
but but yet we had this big rally you
know with the vaccine
on wall street is wall street already
sort of factoring in
that dark winter mentality was that sort
of baked in there already
i think what we were seeing this past
week was a rally because of pfizer and
because of the vaccine i think the dark
winter
is is most likely if it was going to
happen it's still going to happen
because you look at the time frame
of what happens with a vaccine pfizer's
vaccine is one is the first ever
gene-based vaccine that will ever be
approved which
you make gene-based vaccines and test
tubes instead of cultivating them like
you do
say a polio or yellow fever vaccine and
because of that it's much cheaper it's
easier to produce
you do have a storage issue because of
the temperature you have to keep it at
but if you have a vaccine that comes out
say in the first of december
it's going to take logistically a week
to get to places
around the country for people to get
that vaccine you obviously give it to
first responders first
you'll give it to your people that are
most vulnerable your nursing homes
but it's a three-week period with pfizer
it's 28 days when moderna
you take the first shot and then the 21
dater
later 21 days later you take the second
shot so we're looking at a month
process at least from the time they
first ship those vaccines till
it goes into people's bodies and is in
people's bodies enough for that second
shot for people to actually have
some type of immunity to it and in that
time
the everybody's predicting we could have
up to
uh four hundred thousand deaths total we
could have two hundred thousand
uh cases a day of covid so i think we're
still in for a really rough time
ahead of us with cobit unfortunately
until this vaccine
is able to get out there and start
taking effect
yeah that would seem to me in a rough
time for the foreseeable future
for the airlines the cruise lines
anything travel related right
absolutely it's an absolute nightmare
for all those that you mentioned i mean
who wants to get on a cruise i mean
people were stuck there on cruises for
months people don't want to risk that
bermuda has done give me a good example
being is an hour and a half
hour and 45-minute flight out of jfk
it's a great place to go there's very
little coven however if you get covered
you're stuck there
and so people don't are not traveling
because they don't want to get stuck
places because there's a chance they can
get covered if you get in the united
states you can always
effectively drive back to your home or
wherever you want to be
i think cruises are the same way people
are scared to get on cruises
people don't necessarily want to travel
and because of that
until we get a vaccine until we get some
type of comfort and safety
look at amc and look at movie theaters
we have a lot
of businesses that are dependent upon
that vaccine but still
late at the end of the tunnel to to be
sure what is there an industry
you'd love to be in right now or one
that you definitely would not want to be
in right now
yeah uh look biotech i mean i think
pfizer to me is the one that is going to
benefit huge from this vaccine they had
it first
they also didn't take any government
money and operation warp speed so they
can price this
at a way where they can make money
they're going to have a
100 million vaccines by the end of the
year 50 million rather by the end of the
year 1.3 billion next year
that 1.3 billion because they priced
them about 20
each that's about 26 billion dollars in
revenue that you're going to accrete
to pfizer next year that's on a 50
million billion dollar revenue company
you're looking at 50 jump in revenue
with pfizer so i think your biotechs
because of the fact that this is the
first gene-based
vaccine that will ever be approved that
is a huge step
and a seismic shift in the medical
industry what
i have to give you a chance to give a
shout out
to your charity work because i know
you've worked for years for at-risk
youth in particular and now with a group
based in
memphis especially is the focus how has
this pandemic
changed that work it's changed it
significantly memphis inner city rugby
is a group i work with
a gentleman named shane young i think
he's one of the best in the world
at what he does they've changed kids
lives there they've taken
what is about a 60 dropout rate in
memphis which is
some of the worst child poverty in north
america and they change it to 100
graduation rate in high school but also
a hundred percent of those kids
are going somewhere after so they're
going to military
trade school or college after that
they've given out over a million dollars
in scholarships to these inner city kids
but because of the pandemic we realize
there's a gap
and there's a lost generation that could
happen in our inner cities
because they went to remote learning so
with remote learning you have to have a
computer our kids don't have computers
you have to have wi-fi our kids don't
have wi-fi they can't go to school so
literally
you had kids because of where they were
and because of the situation they're
born into weren't able
to go to school and you're seeing that
all across the country it's a
terrible thing that will make these
inequities that people talk about
even greater and so what we've done in
memphis what shane young has done
has reached out to teach for america who
gave us a classroom we got computers
donated by
mike novogratz the really philanthropic
billionaire who
helped beat the streets this wrestling
program that's fantastic and inner
cities
get started and stay funded got us
computers
and so we're actually able to have
remote learning for these kids so they
don't lose out
and miss out of being in school because
of where they are this shutdown has
really affected kids
in specifically low-income areas
well thank you so much for all the work
that you're doing to help with that
and uh thanks for sharing some time with
us today john layfield we appreciate it
always great to talk to you lisa
new from the fox news podcast network my
name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
chris nikitch made history this week he
became the first ever athlete with down
syndrome to complete an ironman
triathlon
he had a 17-hour time limit and he
finished in 16 hours 46 minutes and nine
seconds
in that length of time chris who was 21
swam
2.4 miles rode 122 miles on a bicycle
and ran the length of a marathon the
special olympics twitter account said
chris inspired people around the world
as he set a guinness world record
he crossed the finish line wearing a
shirt that featured his motto of
one percent better every day the day
after that he tweeted
a year ago i wrote chris world champ
anything is possible tanya j powers fox
news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
guy benson
what's on your mind on saturday
journalists
social media feeds were filled with
images of anti-trump voters
flooding into the streets of major
american cities to celebrate the
projected outcome of the election many
of the revelers were wearing masks but
there was very little social distancing
but because journalists were happy
this was treated as a good thing hours
later following an upset in a college
football game
students at notre dame rushed the field
to celebrate another kind of outcome
these students represent a low-risk
population were outdoors
and were overwhelmingly wearing masks
albeit without social distancing
sound familiar well the response for
many in the media was not
wagging fingers and scolding the
students for causing a potential super
spreader event
it seems some outdoor mask wearing
jubilant crowds are okay
when media figures share their
celebration but not okay in other
contexts which has
nothing to do with science of course and
everything to do with politics
this is guy benson host of the guy
benson show
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at fox news
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
it's the perino and stirewalt i'll tell
you what podcast dana perino of the five
and fox news political editor chris
stirewall dissect the ins and outs of
national politics
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes